so in all likelihood donald trump is not
nearly as
rich as he claims to be we know that
donald trump
inflates the value of his real estate
when it's for the purposes of claiming a
higher net worth
or when it's for the purposes of
securing a loan but minimizes the value
of his real estate when it's
uh an effort to avoid taxation but this
story is just kind of weird
because presumably donald trump is a
billionaire
the question is to what degree is he a
billionaire and yet in the last few
months
donald trump has taken sixty five
thousand dollars in
optional federal pension payments for
former presidents
since he left office in january and you
might recall that
during his presidency trump made a very
big deal out of donating his
presidential salary back to different
federal agencies maybe some charities
maybe it was just agencies
and he doesn't need the money and all of
that different stuff and yet
billionaire donald trump is now taking
65 000 from the presidential
pension fund now you might remember
the congressional uh the not the
congressional
the constitution requires that
presidents take a salary while
in office they can donate it back fine
but there's nothing constitutionally
that says an ex-president must
take their pension now this is of course
completely within trump's rights to do
but i find it strange to some degree
because if you look at a more realistic
estimate of donald trump's net worth
it's 2.3 billion dollars relative to 2.3
billion dollars
65 000 is point zero
zero two eight percent of his net worth
so to think about it
in in terms that might be more uh
applicable
to the average person this is equivalent
to someone with the median american net
worth which is 121 thousand dollars
going through a process to request three
dollars and 40 cents
think about that for a second if you
retire from a job or you get laid off or
whatever
and someone comes to you and they say
sir if you want
you can request a pension you go through
this process
and we'll give you three dollars and
forty cents
would most people go through that
trouble if their net worth is a hundred
and twenty one thousand
that's what donald trump is doing here
so what's going on i mean it reminds me
of you know
people who who go to the bank to cash a
check for 12 cents
the upside is by taking this
he seems to recognize he's no longer the
president because this is a federal
pension for
ex-presidents so maybe that's sort of
like an upside here
uh and being a former president comes
with many perks there's lifetime secret
service protection
uh there's travel reimbursements there's
medical insurance there's a budget for
an office and staff and vita
the presidential library maybe they have
to fundraise for the presidential
library now i don't that i don't
remember uh but the point is
in terms of the fen the pension it's not
mandatory so
is trump just so greedy
and so cheap that he won't turn anything
down
and he'll go through the process of
getting something that is the equivalent
at his net worth
of 3.40 for a person of average or
median net worth
maybe he needs the money because a lot
of that net worth
is completely illiquid is he desperate
i don't know we've talked about those
controversial loans
that we knew would start to come due
during what would have been his second
term and thankfully
is not because he lost maybe that's
related but i find that there's
something
sort of strange about it and maybe it's
a simple i mean let me know what you
think
maybe it really is as simple as donald
trump
uh just can't turn any money down
because of his personality and because
of who he is
um maybe there's some other explanation
i don't know but billionaire
multi-billionaire donald trump
going through the process of requesting
filing for and obtaining what is
for his level of net worth equivalent to
three dollars worth of
a federal presidential pension for
ex-presidents
am i the only one finding something
weird about that let me know
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation
because they're either dry or boring or
don't taste that good or
they don't satisfy your cravings but our
sponsor monk pack
is completely different because monk
pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture and yet
they have only 140 calories
one gram of sugar and only two to three
net carbs perfect
for the low sugar or keto diet they come
in
fantastic flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
blueberry almond vanilla and the new
flavor
peanut butter i've been a fan for a long
time i always have them in my pantry
it is a perfect snack and if you don't
love them as much as i do
you get all your money back they also
now have a subscription feature which i
love it'll save you ten percent on every
order
and it ships automatically you'll get
twenty percent off when you go to
monkpack.com and use the coupon code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video